[Music]
it's it's the autumn and uh
that's exciting that it's fall because
it means carnivals carnivals are
starting to pop up everywhere and people
love carnivals people love them
not me
i do not like carnivals in movies
carnivals are always portrayed as this
perfect romantic date but i've taken a
date to a carnival it's terrifying
the whole time i'm waiting for someone
to come out from behind the fun house
with a burlap sack and just capture my
girlfriend
and then use the sack for the dry slide
that's what i think is about to happen
listen to me it's a community
of drifters
drifters
for some when there's one drifter in a
town everybody freaks out they're like i
saw that man they call soup lurking in
the park with a binder
where you get a group of drifters like a
nice little community of drifters that
erect a weird metal village in a parking
lot
hey that's a carnival
that's a fun time for the whole family
you wouldn't trust them with your kid
but we do trust them with everyone's
kids
and some of the rides you have to leave
your belongings with these creeps
too harsh
it's like it's okay honey just leave
your purse with that guy we'll get on
the cyclone yeah hang it on his hook
hand that's perfect
i feel like it's the only job where they
do a background check just to make sure
you have killed someone
and what's off-putting about the whole
thing is it wasn't there
yesterday carnivals just show up it's
like a makeshift village a bunch of
weirdos slapped together in the middle
of nowhere like burning man
and the whole thing runs on a generator
are you listening
a generator
generator
you know those things you only trust
when you have to like after a hurricane
that's what the whole thing runs on
they're like let's start the carnival
get on everybody
put your children on the ferris wheel
your precious mortal babies
load them into this little crate we wash
once a year with a low-powered hose
and hoist them into the air as you have
to tempt god himself to strike them down
and you pay for that how is it romantic
is my point it's not a good date the
rides are terrifying bumper cars i've
been on a bumper car recently how's that
a recreational activity
getting rear-ended
you wait in line for whiplash
there's always one kid in there who's
like way older than the other children
he already has his license
just palming the
wheel signaling
then there's one kid whose car doesn't
work and you'd think the kid with his
license would leave that kid alone but
no
he's making beautiful three-point turns
so he can just keep ramming into them
and the kid's like i paid for this
this was 20 tickets
dummy
and i think it's because carnivals
haven't changed that's why they're so
scary they haven't changed since the
1930s it's like going to this weird
forgotten part of europe
you know they have their own money
that's like tokens
they have their own food their own way
of doing things it's kind of like epcot
but like for some forgotten eastern
european country that epcot doesn't give
a about
that's why all the games are so dark and
negative they're always just like
kill the dog
that's right step right up and kill this
dog
and we do we play the games we want to
win
why
to win like a stuffed animal that's like
a counterfeit version of a cartoon tv
character
that's impressive for your day like look
honey
i won you a stew from family goo
he's filled with shredded chinese
newspapers
it's not a good date
they're not romantic i just i feel like
you leave sluggish from the fried dough
bruised from the unsafe brides and at
night instead of your girlfriend
clinging on to you she's just squeezing
her off brand homar slamson doll
when you squeeze his foot he goes to
[Applause]
[Music]